yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I
mean engaged I'm life I hope I am as
usual the question is everything's all
right or not yeah quick message message
from the chat would be great to learn if
that is really working yeah I'm on a
little bit later than usual one hour
later than the usual ten in the evening
central european time but we had an
evening of football tonight so i felt
it's not a bad idea to start one hour
late we had many teams at Europe playing
so I guess it's not bad to catch not
collide with that ok i will start with a
game here as soon as i get some feedback
about the state of the live broadcast
yep someone says this life so I'm life
ok cool so I'm going to go for a five
minute game playing PT crop Capri here
and i am from it's a Cypress I think if
i'm not mistaken i've played him before
i am playing a queen queen pawn opening
here playing something slowish to start
with oops yeah something something solid
to get into the right kind of drift for
this kind of blitz game yeah sortez is
life yeah good so I'm just developing my
pieces here it's a very healthy setup
now Bishop a6 was a threat actually but
you didn't react to it I mean ok threat
is a bit strong but an idea let's say
that a wild germ that black did not
really felt like him preventing ok he
tries to play be five I guess hmm
okay b5 it's something that you can do
it doesn't really hurt much okay so
maybe Bishop to d3 yeah i'm just being
solid here before i have c4 it's very
equal position that's not an opening i
regularly play but i wanted to try it
out here it's quite funny what the black
players doing is exactly the setup that
that i am playing against it so it's a
little bit like playing I'm playing
myself here someone asks does rapid
chess help in classical time games yeah
I think it can help and especially if
you have problems with your with your
time management then it can help to play
some rapid chess together better yet to
get better with the decision-making in
limited time in this case it can really
help yeah I'm regrouping a little bit
it's really not much going on now like
it's somewhat more active a little bit
not a very exciting game rapid chess can
also help for classical time games to
test out opening ideas you know it's
often a good idea to check new things
new ideas in in rapid chess because it
is less usually less important game than
a classical time control game and if
something goes wrong I mean it's not
that terrible
okay I wonder what is he going for push
up somewhere I don't know really I have
a look at the d6 porn okay it's going
back hmm yeah i don't know i can also
take I mean it's really really unexcited
this position is it going for before
maybe okay maybe I can get an H five
still feels very equal i'd rather be
black a little bit but it's not a not a
big deal see going before now i can go
queen d 3 or something still don't feel
that this is this is anything important
yeah maybe he can go quincy form okay
i'm going to check on g6 first and now
here
hmm I mean I can do this that's that's
not a big deal Quincy for a status idea
I don't know sorry maybe you can go
currency for but i can go Queen d2 for
example as a question did I see if John
the Ptolemy's refer you to my book on
the channel yes yeah I sent don jon the
book to have a look and he told me a
couple of days ago that he wanted to do
it in short order so well he finally
managed last weekend it seems
interesting / should be there I wonder
if night which is not to g4 some kind of
idea night h 2 nite chef why it could
easily be a be wrong approach
I played that well I mean I really have
no active idea okay let's do this so
night for f5 night h6 fe 4 hmm I know 94
f 59 age 66 only for it looks like I
could have some chances there King g7 is
a bit surprising to me mmm takes h6 fe
for coming takes the form King Teague's
king I don't know I think that's
interesting yeah it was far too far too
slow i should have played that much
quicker and instead he just gives me
that night gives me that bishop here I'd
Soviet move it was probably some some
kind of some kind of mouse slip
threatening on f7 and now he gives me
the Queen while I was weird he really
had a better position for most of the
game but then blended to pieces in short
order okay i'm don t this is Egypt or
Iraq or something there's no way to find
that out yet seems doesn't display the
Egypt Egypt yeah I think it was a mouse
labelled yeah this Bishop g5 okay I'm
going for the time on off that's a line
that I'm currently thinking about them
incorporating into my repertoire
I'm actually wondering if I'm sorry if
the tomorrow could be in a good subject
for a book it is um really am
interesting line in Sicilian and
certainly of interest to many to many
people and as I am learnt when when I
wrote mm sorry my voice is somewhat
shaky um as I learned when I wrote the
names of book if you write a book um
about an opening you really will learn
it I mean you definitely gain some good
knowledge there about it okay what about
this here Queen a form maybe that could
be a good idea no this should be for
check hmm is there are some kind of
tricks queen if five now that I don't
see a great trick mm so i can take on d
2 here and go to be eight that is
certainly okay but i was thinking yeah
but i don't think there's something
substantially better yeah Black has I
guess equalized in this position King c3
is a bit surprising as I'm planning this
and rook c8 anyway and it feels like a
bit if it fits a bit weird why you would
run into those some
tempo moves maybe rook here okay let's
push with temple um why not right about
then yeah if you want to buy a signed
copy of my book just write them and
write a meal to me you can also go to my
channel and there will be the video will
be on the on the channel page that gives
an overview about the book and I someone
posts links and things about it yeah
it's um it's much easier it's hard for
me to multitask things like that playing
the game chatting everything at once um
yeah why the time I love and not the
night off and one one thing is the night
off is of course a good line no question
but it has has been kind of if you if
you want them it's it's kind of firm
that's been covered to death yeah in in
books and DVDs and so on and one problem
of the night off is a little bit that it
has very a very large um amount of
forced lines where you where you have to
learn um where you have to learn things
by heart and in the time on off you have
this is a bit less forcing and it means
that you quite often can get by with
some general ideas and I always liked it
if there's some kind of geological
thread let's aim in an opening that
helps you to learn it better and in them
as i said in the night off this this can
be
a tricky tricky thing as you really have
to know everything move my mouth so what
happens here he wants to check on g5 and
check me here mmm the ticket rook h3 is
mate meat is not good not good for me at
least
oh that's not so easy
yeah g4 it's not what I wanted really
not but I don't see a move here really
don't see a good move I mean if you look
here or something I don't know i have
him took him no I'm that's question yeah
i'm considering now if I i mean i'm
considering to do another book project
somehow but i'm not really sure about it
i was thinking i want to learn the the
the tomorrow for some some Sicilian line
and i was thinking if it's maybe an idea
to 22 we are to combine that learning
experience with the with the authoring a
book about it but there's nothing really
um yeah there's no one there are no very
concrete plans is what i'm trying to say
so now if five and before I want to be
active that was the idea here be active
mean he has an extra porn but it's not
so clear how helpful the poorness
my king is very active FY 3 is maybe
here rather 43 oh that is very active
the King there how does it stop daddy
porn actually ok maybe King e1 actually
not sure I kinky one
yo rooks is six is an interesting move
now just trying to trade Roxy to check
is now prevented and the point is
dangerous it really is I go there okay
let's push this first and then king of
22 also just attacking the G porn
decided that that's two protected passes
or connected passes yeah I've seen
John's review hmm it was a very um very
nice positive one
yeah now he has to trade one look and
then the pawns will do the do the job
yeah he resigned okay let's see new game
has a good start someone asks are you
pro I'm a pro well I'm not the chest
professional for in terms of a chess
player but I teach professionally and
yeah write books and videos stuff like
that so I don't earn money by playing
really not good enough for that I mean I
can win the occasional price but I'm not
playing a lot but mostly I'm teaching
yeah I'm kind of tempted for to do a new
book but as I said unsure unsure about
things it's also I'm the thing is
writing a book is um it's something that
is not a very economically as yeah
sensible decision you really don't don't
earn that much money from it but it is
it's nice to do you've got something you
produce something which is a rare thing
I mean if you if you have a if you have
a job that is some but is typical to
produce something I like you you build a
house or whatever you really see a
result of your work and it's a nice
thing if you write a book and you have
something in your hands at the end of
the process so yeah I'm requesting a new
five minute game but I don't get one
please get me a game not much not much
traffic here maybe many European players
are still um yeah watching the the rest
of the euro qualifiers half half Europe
was playing tonight I watched watched
the game
I'm Scotland Germany Germany hematite
Brown is the opponent from Antarctica
this is cute um quenette's fianchetto
yeah germany won won that match 32
Scotland did a good job there they were
able to they were able to twice um
equalize the Squam there's a question of
what around what rating are my students
it's a very right range from let's save
twelve thirteen hundred up to 2,100
2,200 I have no particular limit their
the question do I know where most of my
viewers are located by Google Analytics
or something like that yes I know most
of them are from from Germany or Germany
UK and and the United States so a 95 I
think that this is actually not great
but I wonder Jenna Bishop chinks
yeah that is not great but I wonder is
it bishop age six or bishop t tool for
this the reason exactly why this is not
grade maybe bishop age 6 i'm not sure I
want to know that that night xt5 is not
really great yeah this is played on the
ICC the internet internet chess club an
important line is Bishop g7 take stakes
be 494 quindi for check and widest much
better if he takes a one Queen a 1 f6
that will be some compensation for me
but this move okay I would have thought
that Roxy one should be pretty good one
problem is Bishop g7 i will take or
before and the nidus trapped I don't
really know where he's going now with
his bishop where's he going it seems
very very weird hmm i don't know i don't
see a move i mean if he goes back to
have 60 ever yeah here i have at least
before Roxy to was also good yeah looks
it to a strong actually that will win a
piece I guess yeah and this is the
business tonight okay so he's got them
he's got the two pawns yeah b5 is still
rather I mean here's some play let's say
this is what I want to try try to say
how to do this here let's go a form
prevent Bishop f5 I mean in blitz chess
at least he has a reasonable idea you
can just push b5 and just push his pawns
forward Bishop a for now is an idea meow
true where to put this not so easy
rookie to Bishop b5 maybe Queen d2 with
a tempo maybe queen a for now then I go
okay one something like that it's not so
it's not that easy it's not that easy to
do
I want to go bishops III and trade that
off getting rid of one of its bishop
would be wit bishops would be helpful I
guess a good thing is whenever he pushes
some c4 I get night to deform see 494 I
know I'm and then let's do this this is
better if i can trade that bishop would
also be really helpful 92 94 that's nice
that's nice yeah that should be a pretty
pretty young doable technical task yep
up to c4 and okay you can push this
forward but i'll also be quick down i
need quick player with e5
yeah I don't know maybe b3 is an idea
pushing very quickly maybe if it does
not do that I don't really know I mean I
will probably win stuff takes Knight
takes even for a tempo and then look c5
that looks quite convincing someone says
video gone that doesn't sound right you
should have you try to refresh ok now it
says returned ok um yeah be too that is
still kind of tricky let's do this for
possible route be too
yeah this advanced pawns are always some
danger associated with them as I already
set early on yeah sometimes twitches is
acting up and the only way to to handle
this is to refresh them unfortunately so
here let's push this Bishop see two know
it takes so let's fatigue here and look
a one maybe grabbing the open file yep
yeah it's not it's not totally easy here
rook is six maybe I don't see any
dangerous invasion at the moment g5
fruit f5 I don't know I have to be quick
you cannot take you five because of
Bishop c4 look at four maybe that's
maybe a point
okay check on is six outs of Bishop b5
check if I need it yep I need it d 67
probably d6 king be success d7 check
yeah i think my pants do the job i
pawned my pawns is wrong it's a it's a
single porn yep and he resigns nice okay
that is a nice winning streak three wins
for the start if i'm not mistaken did I
let the three wins right yep three wins
okay yo any questions guy it's been
quite quite them hmm slow here on them
on the twitch chat there any questions
that I might be able to answer what
about the world cup are you looking
forward to watch the chess world cup it
will start just in two or three days I
believe there's a question have sales on
the book been positive yeah I think so I
didn't ever hear from my publisher
here's some or they are kind of slow and
giving me information but I heard from
German retailers that it would sort
pretty nicely i also have soared i also
have sold quite a bit of sign copies
that's a question will you be doing
commentary for the world cup um mirror
maybe maybe I mean I don't I want to
worm daily coverage but if there is
something that looks interesting why not
mmm opinion about the Kings gambit yeah
that's a simple actually the Kings
gambit is on well it's not a bad
surprise weapon maybe but for regular
use it's just a little bit too unsound I
guess for four wide Claire so I would
only recommend to play a term very
occasionally of like someone says it is
irritating to see chess players talk
during a match in a movie like pawn
sacrifice or is that the only way to
make your chest movie interesting um
yeah that's difficult to say I mean I I
didn't see the movie so I it's hard to
comment on it in particular um in
general I think it's not so easy to
learn to do chess in a movie it's not an
easier proposition simply because it is
as we all know it is a rather difficult
game and I mean it can be maybe made
interesting for me with things like
psychology or interesting characters or
so on and I don't know maybe this way
maybe you have to adjust some things a
little bit to make it more interesting
but it should be should have some kind
of yeah realistic flavor to it if you
have I mean if they really portray what
championship Mitch they're like the
Reykjavik mentioned it is some somehow
implied that spicy and Fisher will talk
over the boys would be kind of
ridiculous mmm
so 95 yeah he this is a very weird very
weird term opening result his key gave
me the c5 square which I found helpful
but he still has some pressure I wonder
if I did something wrong here very
strange that's a question am i
interested in math at all hmm well I
mean not not honor I mean I don't I
wouldn't look at some math problems
let's say for recreational ideas or so I
don't think I'm not particularly
interested in mathematical problems for
for entertainment or something like that
yeah at this position this suck it
really does suck whoa he has a huge
advantage he with the advanced pawns I
couldn't get a blockhead going wow yeah
c6 in particular
yeah white is much better him really wow
okay let's block this a little bit yeah
I don't think that the actor was playing
a Spassky looks really a little bit like
Spassky or at least they managed it with
makeup or whatever liev schreiber I
think it's the name or schreiber he
looks kind of similar yeah may I see six
is coming this is really really really a
problem or b6 also a problem Wow g6 is
just winning and I couldn't do anything
against it I really couldn't wow it's
really played it very strange at the at
the very beginning I don't know yeah
there's a question is there I've have
some recommendation for a chess tactics
book yeah I think that the the online
resources some are completely enough to
do to do things on tactics i recently
got a book this is this is reasonable
what a terrible game what went wrong
there that's really strange
especially considering that what why did
here with 35 and suffice is it looks
completely anti positional but maybe I'm
wrong there and I just made a make
mistakes here 95 and night if I may be
94 was wrong I cannot believe that I
museum okay let's see um let's go tip
tip from if I have a tip for preparing
for a tournament no preparation an open
event um it's well it's not a bad idea
for for preparation for an event to get
your tactics tactics am into some sharp
state so i usually recommend to increase
the tactics training so that you have a
better yeah that you kind of have a good
feel for what happens in the calculation
of sense of a game so um if you want my
advice do some tactics training um it
depends a little bit on on your playing
level you can just use an online side of
course um a good idea for a stronger
player to to do tactics training is some
stew to do well to solve endgame studies
this is also what the very top players
do a few if you have there have been
some some video recordings of Magnus
Carlsen's preparation for the World
Championship match in 2013 and and he
they they did they did many a end game
and game studies
someone says it's amazing how you know
the opinion of every professional player
on that very issue I'm not sure what
this is referring to to the preparation
thing I know that that the tactics thing
is this tactics thing is this very
common recommendation I think it goes
back to pour vinegar some good for good
book for end games yeah I always
recommend the same two books this is the
100 end games you must know by de la vía
and Garcia for basic and games and the
end game manual by Mark turetsky father
for complicated end games and turn and I
think this is basically what you need
you don't really know don't really need
much more there are more good at chem
books but this is totally enough so I
have to think about this a little bit
here or they had to push stuff him
there's a question do it do you have a
record on my blitz games can I make a
playlist for my favorite blitz games
would be probably interesting huh there
are so many of them um now it's it's
it's really lots of work to go through
all the games i didn't find the time to
do that there's a question um if i want
to be 2,000 if those two endgame books
are enough for 2200 rating yes
absolutely yeah absolutely i think that
i mean if you I mean I've got 2,400
raiding you know with the bought long
time control chest and I don't know all
of those books for sure well my
theoretical and games are not that good
anyway but it's um it's just I mean it's
totally enough really totally enough
okay so we can we trade some stuff here
and this is of course welcome the
queenside pawn structure is very
favorable for me I just have to make
sure that i'm not getting checkmated
which can happen I mean it really can
happen so what I need is a night on f4
and c3 this would be really helpful to
attack to attack d5 but I would also
like to trade Queens after a queen trade
my position is strategically very very
nice oh he does that it's surprising
yeah his see porn is is terminally week
actually the only question is does he
have something with Bishop before
something annoying yeah so I'm going
here
the one hand 100 n games you must know
us by hassles hassles I mean I cannot
really pronounce it correctly della via
Spanish player there's also question for
a good book that helps evaluating
positions this is not so easy many am i
mean the important part of evaluating
position is really unimportant and
virtuous to simply know lots of
positions and and study study games why
do the top layer study and game
compositions because it is very helpful
for disciplined calculation yeah I
really have to calculate very precisely
in those end games and it helps you to
get some creative ideas because the
ideas as you say they don't pop up that
often in real life play but they they
simply help you to to be creative okay
I'm looking a little bit at that is six
and Bishop them books you one yeah this
is a nice position but I don't see how
to break through here 93 mmm doesn't
really help
yeah maybe i can after the bishop moves
i can sacrifice on e6 and 285 at this
interesting that's a bit a bit tricky I
don't see a way forward as nice as it
looks 56 yeah who do I have how do I
make some progress in this position most
of my chess books are in English I mean
like ninety-five percent of them there's
not that much published in German maybe
I can can do this maybe getting the
bishop to f5 I don't know if that helps
much probably not
I wouldn't have aged 4 as an idea night
each one and h4 to get the Knight to f4
but probably also not helping that much
that's a bit risky edge for maybe not
netting me that much
okay so i won't sacrifice that the
exchange now and try to win like that it
is indeed a bit dicey but let's see I'm
not sure that this is good actually that
closing of the position that should
actually be helpful for me so it's a
rather nice position again but can I win
this is the real problem the real
question I've got quite a number of
pawns rolling now not not pre moving on
this
I let's say that's a very nice position
but can you win that's a real problem
really a question I hope that this works
I is doing some pre move tricks great
stuff baby after being completely
dominated whatever we know in time ok
anyway that's the right result actually
but it was a weird time scramble ok um
so what do we have what do I think about
the Scotch game yeah the Scotch is a
very interesting alternative to them to
the to the other um II 45 openings the
good thing about the Scotch game is that
white is actually insured of an open
game yeah in something like I'm the
window pass or some Italian game with
see 3d three for example it's rather a
close game and in the in the Scotch game
you you really know that the position
will be open so this is a nice feature
of the of the scotch yeah you really get
to see through the soil could very very
often since I've been trying out them
the Sicilian a bit in recent games I
really had to have to learn that
everybody and their uncle they played
the c32 sayin it's really a pest and I
have not studied that yet that's not
very exciting
yeah at least him black doesn't have any
particular problems i think someone says
a good players always lucky i don't know
who said that what I actually like for
44 chest is I mean this is some song by
daft punk get lucky we work all night to
get lucky this is probably right for
many for many strong chess players okay
let's trade stuff him
yeah it's not very exciting but what can
you do I have equalised i guess and now
we'll try to to do something and now i
actually have a little something maybe
gaining the bishop hell so I'm getting
taking here why is it taking c5 know so
I really gain to the bishop hell yeah I
really think that and it's very often
the case that people some people have
the image that they are lucky in some
way and it is quite often not the case
of luck but simply hard work a funny an
example that will be very well known to
German people is some the very well
known um football play and later coach
of the german national team from France
Beckenbauer who's always been attributed
with being very lucky and the thing is
that everybody who ever worked with him
as a coach especially said that he was a
very very tough workout studied the
opponent's teams in much detail with
video analysis and so on which nowadays
is totally standard but like 25 years
ago it really wasn't and he was working
like every possible minute to to improve
his team's chances so it's not just luck
for those four for many for many people
who are attributed with being lucky they
really do work very hard
so um my bishop pair do I really have
something I mean this dust is really
help checking here's Bishop Bishop back
it's not helping that much yeah that's
just bring the King up bishop a6 I
wonder if that is a move home I go
before mmm that's surprising I didn't
expect that move if I can go f5 or let's
start with this maybe then F 595
yeah the two bishops but how exactly am
i doing something with it I think this
and then if five is good can essentially
pre move this gaining more space
ok back here yeah semen actus tiny was a
pro footballer and also an excellent
chess player I think he played in them
in the second English league will not
mistaken idea played on the national
team the Norway national team okay um
let's go here I want to start playing
the French what should I study mean the
fringe there a couple of books on the
French of course a very prolific French
authors of course John Watson very
well-known international master from the
US he is also um involved with the ICC
the cell commentary and he also will
have a video series coming up on chess
openings he also made a video series for
the ICC on the French that you might
want to want to check someone says they
made a they started to to learn to play
em 11 d 4 tournament play but feel that
it's difficult to get adjust adjust it
to their positions and yeah it takes a
while it really takes a while the
question is why exactly what do you want
to play both if you if you are ok with
them with e for it's not a bad idea to
branch out a little bit but maybe you
will never get to that level that you
have with your main move I know from
experience and sometimes like to play
one day for for for a change of flavor
and they always feel that this is not
yet my my home turf so one it's
difficult and ideas if you want to
get more knowledge about default style
positions to pick maybe Im two or three
players depends on two or three players
that can serve as a role model for for
your for your play yeah for example
someone like Boris Gelfand is an
excellent sample player he's a he plays
some only very sound stuff it's never
playing any fishy stuff let's say he
still wants to make some pressure in his
games so it's it's good ambitious but
not crazy this kind of
middle-of-the-road term approach I've
take Dre F the Russian Grand Master
those if you wanted level below below
galfond those kind of people excellent
role models for you for your opening
repertoire ok one more game would be
nice I requested it but didn't didn't
start yet yeah it's a bit late it's a
bit later than usual subha me who's that
their name in them nope sweden at FMS
that's a pretty generic okay to
celebrate my book once again let's go
with the names oh maybe I get the hoop
in a variation yeah maybe Knight f3 nope
not no hip now this is a line that I
have in my book it's one of the few true
innovations of my book I have to say
there are I mean I have many little new
ideas this is 25 27 is a a rare rare
idea he happened not so bad
there's a question do I what is my
Buddhist my opinion about having in
another sport for being physically
trained for long tournament at others
yeah that's a fan that's an excellent
idea I think it's a very very useful and
um I totally agree it's a great idea to
have some some sporting activity that
you um that you do besides chess why
does nobody on the top level play the
cheek or on defense yeah the knight on
c6 is not that well placed if it is not
a very reliable defense that she bore in
queens in the in the Queens gambit I I
think you probably refer to it is not a
super reliable line I mean black can't
play that it's not terribly bad but it
is kind of it is tricky Black has to be
very precise and it just doesn't pay off
really on the very top level to play a
slightly am dicey opening line when you
have many good ones available yeah they
really feel no need to try something
something um yeah something offbeat when
there are so many reliable Queens gambit
sand whatever if you want some some
fighter they will often just play a
king's indian or something like that um
yo so he has some activity going 95 in
particular is this energy maybe to trade
some stuff it's kind of dangerous here
this pollution
yeah I wonder ever I should just take
him let's do that it's a bit
unconventional but training stuff is
probably helpful 94 as a threat now I'd
like to play Knight f6 for more trades
but you will have 95 which is looking
kind of uncomfortable maybe it's not
such a big deal but it looks looks a bit
dangerous at least it was quick what I
did taking only two was a weird decision
actually there's a question will i be
going to the word blitz and rapid in
berlin yes i will i will go to Berlin
and if I understand correctly I'm not
allowed to play it's a 2500 plus only
event but I will be a there as a
spectator are there any chest towards
that I wish existed interesting I am NOT
nav no particular idea at the moment
we have excellent tools nowadays of
course but i don't i don't really
nothing comes to mind in particular so
he traded on c4 that's surprising
this a question who's my all-time
favorite player I don't have one I
really don't
may utha always like Calvin turn Kramnik
a lot also Fisher and off the old ones
yeah Rubenstein is the favorite because
he really was revolutionary good at the
time for for strategic chest he really
was I mean having miles miles ahead
compared to many of his peers in his
understanding of the game so oops you
one yeah we get stuff traded maybe that
rook endgame is nice one nice point is
that I'm about two and a half minutes
head on the clock and I have a good end
game definitely so if i go to e7 he SD
five that's unfortunate so probably this
one first
how would how would I define a manual
ask his playing style interesting
interesting question yay Alaska was some
very very strong really strong and I
think it was mostly a pragmatist he was
doing them what what term felt felt
appropriate to him but first and
foremost he was a really really good
tactical player was a very good
calculator and very good in posing
practical problems of course I don't
them I don't think I mean this is this
mumbo-jumbo of talk about him being the
great psychological play and so on I
don't know I mean he may be was more of
a psychologist than many of his peers by
choosing choosing lines but shooting the
right lines of playing against certain
opponents but he also was really really
strong mostly with calculation there are
really some great games by Alaska where
he had a very not much was going on and
then he was simply out playing the
people by taking slight risk slide risks
and he got somewhere yeah very often he
had positions out of the opening that
really sucked because he really was bad
in the opening I mean Lasker's opening
level is probably something like maybe
nowadays people with 2100 or 2200 have
better openings than laska did this is
actually not only true to Alaska this
also I mean cup of blancas openings also
world maybe on master level or so but
what they did afterwards was fantastic
that's a question why do I use the white
blue board and not a brown white or so
the white blue is so cool hmm I don't
know um I mean this is this is the
standard ICC look what I have and in my
in my videos for the channel I do use
something that I like I like that white
blue edits bit cold yeah I have to agree
but I like the like the look hmm what is
she doing here from a classical
variation which was supposed to
something that looks a lot like a real
cozen hmm the knight on c6 interesting
hmm weird ok so I'm going to check here
yeah maybe he wants to if I go a three
wants to cheek and then play that end
gamer porn down it's an interesting
tribe let's do it because my porn
structures not really great but I'm
still not sure about it I have play on
the B file
let's go see form I don't know it's that
really love compensation from luck and
don't I don't know it seems hard to
believe Luke c1 yes b6 i guess that is
this idea okay yeah that sets that's
true that's true oh yeah okay yeah
probably have to do it anyway so Bishop
a6 rooks e5 Kingda to or something like
that Oh c6 yeah that's a bit that's
equal ish maybe Bishop a 6 is actually
move knight c6 be sure basics
interesting that could be an idea txtx
checks rights probably equal probably
equal
we are night be five it's not helping me
a lot we should be five years night 64
unfortunately okay
group 2 8 king in two and a look see one
I think equal stuff there's a question
have i ever met a title player that has
arms full of tattoos no I never met one
absolutely never
sorry for my voice I'm a bit I have a
slight code yeah i still believe it's
around equal i mean i don't really see
much black hair store against Wandy on
the queenside but my central play is
also not bad
g4 maybe someone says they have seen
chess players full of the tools but not
titled once i don't know i never thought
about getting one yeah I actually think
that I'm fine in my space advantage is
helpful and he has some dependencies in
this position f7 is a weakness I could
have taken actually maybe that porn but
oh what is this so there's some kind of
connection issue like pink time is ok
but he his clock is not someone says um
this every move have to do something or
sometimes best to just make a neutral
move um um well no not every move has to
do something but most moves will do will
do something and with good reason you
want to make progress somehow in a game
okay um that's an interesting choice
just f1 it chicks me here maybe going
back as an idea the bishop moves you
here i have this check g5 isn't that
ugly and where is it going be sure
before as a pretty substantial threat I
don't see where his rook is going and
that's the exchange
yeah I think this is six right here or
this one this one probably getting
getting this activated yet he loses this
as well okay probably back over here to
try to invade on c7 and then go over
with the king at porn star dangerous ok
I have to enter with the king there is
no big choice there give up a bonus
right I guess now the upon will march
a fool I guess oh wait up i'm not
screwing this up
mmm no that's enough and I'm not
miscalculating here and six kings you
three take stinks and so on remember
that is a win ice me i miscounted hahaha
i miscounted this end game oh how stupid
is that okay okay that's day that's Roy
yeah mmm yeah it's after midnight okay
um do i own a nice chess set hmm i don't
know it's a it's a regular one nothing
fancy Kosta I don't know maybe like
sixty seventy dollars fifty euros i
think it was nothing nothing fancy um
yeah I was a silly game yeah not winning
this end game was really silly him okay
so we did a slide over time here 15 past
midnight I hope you enjoyed this this
little after football show and I'll be
back again next week next Monday um
probably very likely with the regular
time of 10 p.m. central european time
and 4 p.m. eastern standard time i hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching until
next time bye